buonasera a tutti e benvenuti alla terza
puntata del grande fratello questa
puntata sono una puntata ricca di
emozioni degli amori e soprattutto di
simone infatti è uscita simona grandi la
scorsa settimana ma è stata rimpiazzata
la simona izzo che ancora dentro la casa
in collegamento inoltre abbiamo un'altra
simona pensate un po che si chiama
simula rodriguez
allora per quanto riguarda scene mi sa
che insomma è tommy vee te l'amore mio
io posso dire semplicemente che mi avete
rotto le palle in queste critiche perché
è un ragazzo dolcissimo semplicismo
educatissimo di 25 anni che mi ha fatto
niente di male lo stato e tutti
attaccando solamente perché mio fratello
perché se no forse mio fratello
ok non aver detto nulla e grazie mille
per il tuo intervento insomma ci
auguriamo tutti quanti di geremeas la
smetta di comportarsi in questo modo
assolutamente poco affine alle
strettissime rigide regole di
comportamento che ci sono all'interno
della casa del gf dip
e chiudiamo il collegamento con simona
vogliamo sentire al riguardo anche
l'opinione del dell'altra sorella
insomma di cecilia e chi intatta con lui
tre settimane fa ha dentro la casa del
grande fratello vincita di sicilia.il
riti di vento cecilia ecco qual è il
vostro rapporto insomma qualcosa che hai
detto tu dopo aver visto che si è
comportato così s'è fatto insomma una
figura poco carina avanti tutta italia
ecco quello che posso dire è sempre
stato un poco stimo fratello però non è
cattivo tutte lo dipingono come una
persona che non è un po un posto è
sempre che si comporta così perché è
vero a differenza degli altri qua dentro
lui è vero allora si comporto così pure
io l'ho detto fare attenzione perché poi
magari da fuori pensano che tu sia
mancato
non è maleducato che ho vinto io
gliel'ho detto però poi a luglio il
libero di fare quello che vuole io gli
vorrò sempre bene perché il mio fratello
piano avente va bene sicilia grazie
mille per il tuo intervento
chiudiamo subito collegamento con la
casa e ne sentiamo quello che pensa
invece il diretto interessato
quindicesimi a suggerirmi eccedenti
sinceri mia se allora abbiamo sentito
gli interventi le opinioni tutte e due
le tue sorelle quindi simone cecilia e
volevamo sentire anche cosa ne pensi
duri quello che è successo se insomma ti
vuoi scusare che sarebbe anche carino
nei confronti di tutti gli italiani
stanno guardando a casa guarda hillary
sinceramente io devo scuso ma scusa di
che cosa non hanno fatto niente mi avete
rotto tutti quanti questa gente
bastardi tutti sti maledetti veramente
mi campo gli altri vani sì la gente così
io io glielo dico
l'unico subito allora di fede lo si la
gente consiglio me lo voglio andare
ma stiamo scherzando non ha niente a che
vedere con questa gente mi fanno schifo
io non ho votato ma mi dovete dire se
posso ruotare un pò sfruttarne il
rotondo vogliono vedete non date mi
chiamo con le cose proprio non l'ho
neanche falsa è stata nato il
collegamento per favore congeli mia
grazie grazie regia e volevo sentire
invece le opinioni di carmela carmen di
pietro insomma lei
non si è mai schierata quando ci sono
stati questi vi dice all'interno della
casa vediamo se ha qualcosa da dire
carmeci santi c6 ed è subito sera di
salvatore quasimodo
[Musica]
ognuno sta solo sul cuor della terra
trafitto da un raggio di sole
ed è subito sera allora mi sa che c'è un
problema di audio perché insomma carne
sta recitando le sue solite poesie ma la
domanda era un'altra quindi chiudiamo
subito collegamento e vediamo se invece
gioia giulia dell'elvis una delle
ragazze più seguite appunto di questo
grande fratello vi fa qualcosa da dire
riguardo lei anche lei molto insomma non
si è schierata tanto nonostante abbia un
caratterino particolare e giulia ci sei
ciao italia buonasera a tutti mi chiamo
giulia de les anges nella vita mi occupo
di tendenze e ne racchiude infatti un
esperto di tendenze e nel tempo libero
invece mi occupo di make up tutorial su
youtube e giulia giuliano la
presentazione già fatta giulia senti e
no volevo chiederti cosa ne pensi di
geremia su insomma sono famosa perché ho
partecipato come le donne e ho
corteggiato anche adam ant e che poi è
diventato appunto con il ragazzo e
quando l'ho visto mi di forte che tutto
questo è bello come il sole dev'essere
per forza in parti così è stato papà
chiudiamo anche il collegamento con
giulia mi sa che è appunto ci sono
problemi gravi di audio perché ognuno
dice quello che vuole dire insomma non
non ci capiamo che passiamo invece a
parlare di un'altra concorrente insomma
una delle colonne portanti di questa
casa anche se non è ben vista dagli
altri dagli altri concorrenti di questa
persona è simona izzo che si chiama
veramente si vuole insomma con lei
vado sul sicuro non sbaglio vogliamo
sapere come ha passato questa settimana
simula ci senti ci sei
sì l'ho ritenuto si muova come passato
questa settimana cosa che emozioni hai
provato
una settimana tremenda tragedia sensore
che ri che mi manchi ricche mi senti
ricordatemi ricchi amore mio mi sono
ricordata di quella volta santa cecilia
di roma
adesso non sbaglia uno spettacolo di
cechov ricchi e dal regista mi ha
guardato durante le prove merito siamo
l'attesa è tutta la mia vita io ho avuto
un tuffo al cuore insomma lì ho capito
che sarebbe diventato mio marito
amore mio mi manchi tesoro ci sarà va
bene simone grazie mille per favore puoi
chiamare cristiano all'interno del
confessionale cristiano come passato
questa settimana prenda il clamore
allora questa indecenza
io me ne voglio andare da qui dentro
l'ho già detto il grande fratello devi
fare qualche davanti a tutta italia jo
soy un nome del quello non riesco a
respirare qui dentro c'è troppa polvere
fatemi tornare a trista police
ripetitiva casa mia perché il chiosco
con ombre del duello ed avevi un po per
favore perché il mio ciuffo veramente si
sta rovinando il costato 380.000 e una è
un'indecenza meno male che ci sono le
banane mi consolo anche perché qui
dentro aperte ma se insomma non è un bel
vedere
fa bene cristiano allora abbiamo visto
che risale inventato molto bene
cristoforis ti lascia riunì per sempre e
fino alla fine del programma insomma
vediamo un collegamento allora la
puntata purtroppo termina qui
grazie mille per averci seguito insomma
ci vediamo quindi prossimo e purtroppo
questa puntata mannacio ve ne vado a
casa non vedevo l'ora e comunque è un
bacione da metà in arida alfonso dalla
gialappa's e anche da francese che ci
guarda a casa non vedo l'ora che torno
ciao ragazzi un bacione